22 year old jesus lizardo lizardo is a
very highly thought of young pitcher he
is their number one rated prospect an
electric fastball a very good changeup
lizardo kicks and deals and that's a
hard slider down and in and that's how
the ball game opens up here's marty now
who had yesterday off and he lines the
bases into center field he jumped on the
first one
and singled sharply
so the dimebags have a base runner just
like that here's the pitch and that's a
ground ball to third he was left up with
the chapman goes to second kemp goes to
first they go around the horn and well
turned and these get a 5-4-3 double play
merrill kelly who's been outstanding
gonzo merrill has given up one run or
fewer in three of his four starts this
year so here's grossman the bases are
loaded with two outs
and that one is driven right field
calhoun on the move and he's not gonna
get it
it bounces up over the wall two runs are
gonna score
and the aims are going to take a
first-inning lead or the very hot robbie
grossman comes through again here comes
the 1-2 pitch to biscotti and that's
popped up
a lot of foul room here this one's going
to stay in fair territory though oh
walker makes the catch he almost
stripped over the bag so lizardo a
couple of early runs to work with as he
faces walker
and a high fastball 97 miles an hour and
he blew it right by walker
luna ground ball wider for his backhand
olson flipping lizardo on the bag and
jesus has a one two three second walk
allowed by merrill kelly and that'll
bring up simeon
good curve ball right there comes back
and strikes out simeon that's his first
strikeout tonight 2-2 pitch
on the inside did he go
he did that's a strikeout check swing
strike three here's kevin crone is over
seven this year lizardo's delivery
inside corner strike three call not a
change up freeze is crow and he's going
to looking and that is the third k for
jesus here's le castro second time
around he's leading two nothing he goes
after a fastball and pops it into right
easy chance out there for piscotti he'll
make a one-handed catch and lizardo
survives the lead off single at a wild
pitch so champion at singa with one out
now for canna and it's swung on and
lifted a deep left back as la castro to
the track near the wall at the out of
town scoreboard and up on the ledge and
gone
high arcing blast from marketa his third
of the year with chapman aboard and he
doubles the athletics lead to four
nothing
strike three call grossman with a check
swing and that one had a little bit of
play probably more ball out of the box
but it's a strikeout number three into
his full wind-up and the 2-2 pitch to
biscotti got him swinging he chase off
the plate poor strikeout for kelly but
the eighth strike for two a home run by
canada let him
right there he goes upstairs 96 miles an
hour
chase that you're going to be in big
trouble stretch the offer and that has
popped up behind second base back
peddling is kept the second baseman's
still going still going he'll stay with
it all the way he'll squeeze it and the
inning is over four nothing oakland we
start at the bottom of the fourth and
tony kemp stands in
and strike three caught kemp threw the
bat away
and tried to deep the home plate umpire
but moore was going to have nothing of
it strikeout looking that's five
strikeouts for kelly the one-two
loriano takes
strength recall kelly gets strikeout
number six
calhoun banning sixth in the lineup
against the lefty lizardo leads off the
diamondbacks fifth now here's the
delivery in the 3-2 and calhoun swings
and misses down he goes calhoun
strikes out one away and that'll bring
up nick ahmed here's a 3-2 with one out
and that's taken inside corner ring him
up fastball 97. mariano about four steps
toward right center kelly checks up on a
pitch inside but they ring him up on the
affiliated first that's strike three and
lizardo strikes out three in the fifth
and the diamondbacks have two on making
a bid and starling martay is coming up
here's the 2-2 pitch on the way swung on
a ground ball to third near the back
chapman's off the back on the bag for
one on a hop to first in time for a
double play what a good play by matt 5-3
on the double play at the belt the turn
here's the pitch and that's swung on
ripped to left center lauriana going
back deep in the alley leaping and he
makes the catch as he got just to the
warning track he got a tremendous jump
risardo has struck out seven he has
walked a pair
swing and a fly ball to shallow left and
that's going to fall in front of
grossman for a basement for calhoun
and that looks like it's going to be it
for jesus lizardo as his night's going
to come to an end samara petite his 13th
appearance among the league leaders in
appearances as he always is two on now
and we'll see what they do about chrome
spot he's going to come to the playing
bat for himself the lay kick the pitch
swing and a miss gotta buy him and crone
is beside himself and petite to peralta
and he swings and pops it into the left
that's going to end the inning under
this grossman and he makes a catch and
that'll end the threat and on the other
taylor clark has walked the bases loaded
with two outs and it's going to be a
chance for biscotti
and biscotti's swing sets it down to
third escobar boots it has to go to
first and a nice scoop by walker
is that third now with one out ready at
the letters and the pitch is sky to
center field that should get the run
home well maybe laureato makes a catch
he's got a good arm le castro tanks
here's the throw the castle with the
speed
it gets in divebacks are on the board
it's 4-1
sacrifice fly by starling martay but now
they're two outs in the inning another
one-two
and a fastball right at the knees on the
outside corners right three liam henrik
sought to try to save this we go to the
top of the ninth they have a four to one
lead it's lizardos game to win
and a fastball 96 miles an hour blew it
right by him
breaking ball hit right to kept kept
on the first and that's the ball game